so in this section we are going to talk
about
setting up checkpoints
so let me remind you a little bit about
the bwt so the bwt
matrix is formed by sorting on the
cyclic rotations
of the string that is why
if you search for patterns and the
pattern appears in the string there
should exist
a row that this pattern appears as
prefix
and if the pattern appear at multiple
positions
in the string these rows should be
consecutive like this
in the picture
so this one allows us
to represent the result by using just
two
index the top index and the bottom index
the next property of using bwt
for searching a patent is that we
iteratively
build the buttons from the end to the
start
like this so
searching the patterns using bdbt is an
iterative process
in other words it is
what we do is just updating
the indexes for example in this case
we start
with an empty string so that the indexes
can be from 0 to
13. when we start fighting a
the index is one to six when we add one
more symbol to a that is n a
the index is updated from 9 to 11
and when we add the final a so we have
the we are searching for the pattern a
and a
so the index is three to five okay
so uh let's look at a little bit more
detail
so this is the first column the last
column which is the bwt
uh the index and the last two first
which allow us
to quickly allocate
the positions of a character in
in the first column very quickly so this
is
uh at one iteration so the next
iteration we are
actually moving to this range of indexes
okay so the pseudo code
for the bwt marching is described
as an isolated procedure but if you
believe me
and try to code like this it will take
you a very long time
to run and if you analyze the code
most of the time the program will spend
his time in this region
so updating index is actually a
critical point in this algorithm
it's clear that this way we cannot
update the index in a constant time
so i have to describe
another definition so that we can come
up with a faster approach
let's define the code
of a symbol for an index i and a string
text
as the number of occurrences of symbol
in the first i positions of the string
text for example the curve of the symbol
a
with index 4 in this string is equal to
because there is no
symbol a appearing in the first 1 2 3 4
characters but the count of symbol n
in this string is three
so ah let's look at the
algorithm the again this is the last
column which is the bwt
this is the first column which is
obtained by
sorting the last column this is the
indexes
you can see that here
we add some information over there
so uh for each index e
and for each symbols in the alphabet
we calculate a number that is the count
of the symbol i
sorry the count of the symbol at the
position i
in the last card using the last column
so using this information
we can uh have uh
we can update the
indexes
but can we find it quickly well
it's not clear how to fight quickly in
constant time
so we have to get another information
which is the first
occurrence of the symbol is the first
position
of the symbol in the first column
so this is the first column the first
occurrence of
dollar sign is zero
the first occurrence of a
is one the first occurrence of
b is seven
the first occurrence of m is eight
okay
so using the information about the first
occurrence of the symbol
and also the cult matrix
we can quickly update the
indexes and here you can clearly see
that the indexes can be
updated in constant time
but you notice that i store too much
information here
we don't have enough memory to store
that much information
so there should be a way to bypass this
problem
this is the checkpoint arrays approach
so instead of storing on the
code matrix now we just store
the rows of this matrix the row i
if it is divisible by a constant c
so what happened if we want to calculate
the curve of a symbol
at the at the indexes where
we did not store we can
construct it by using the
information that we stored and looking
back
at some characters for example we look
at the
at position number 10 so we see that a
appear
position number 11 a also appears so the
count
of a at the next
11 is equal to the curve at index
10 plus 2 equal to 5.
similarly when we want to find
the positions of the matching we need to
store the suffix array right
but even we don't need to store the
suffix array
completely we just store it partially
and reconstruct if we need to for
example
and here we at this position we don't
have the
suffix array start so we can go back to
b1
and from big one we go to a1 so at
a1 is the position one here we store
in the suffix array is number five so we
get the information
so in summary bwt
is an approach that you can
march the button very quickly and
efficiently